[Music]
drop your shoulders get down
drop your shoulders
[Music]
you end up
great potential
so it's not strong it just feels strong
to get it but it's not strong so you
gotta suspend your feeling it's not
right but this this is all bracelet come
on
follow it you're bracing here I'm trying
to cut down but there's also the luxury
there so turn this shoulder down there
you go and now consciously a lot
look how slow recovery watch look you do
on will be here you see take the energy
off and now you have your emotional
connection you to tell yourself to calm
down
over again
[Music]
you don't want to let go of the pitbulls
collar okay the stage stay connected
let it down dive in lay down emotionally
let go you wait it out follow it you
brace the night thinner you see you stop
it right there but the energy you know
you hold on to it for a stinky we got
your hand down so if again it looks like
it works slow but it doesn't work it
doesn't work you're finding the
technique
this seems like actually oh yeah she's
done spreading look at her crying at
this speed there's an emotional
importance to it
okay now you can't decide am I going to
grow up and be that fragile person where
my expectation is that the world will
never push on me none of my
relationships will ever push on my
career will not push on me so I will
need to learn how to blend and harmonize
I'm going to always be able to resist
and withdraw and it is never going to
override me that's a pipe dream you have
to use your wisdom and I think anybody
who's at least high school age should
understand how he got it
the ladder is do you get it so you don't
let yourself cry you're not going are
you are broken know you've got some Ally
that outweigh that you caused so in
training especially at this speed you
look for your role in the clash as you
can you see and then you deconstruct the
clash by blending with nagas energy
instead of taking advantage of this slow
pace but evenings at this rate you can
tell just like I can tell I don't I
don't need to go let me see if you can
hold on to my grip at a little faster
speed I know you can't from the amount
of internal flexion I'm feeling
from the second you touch me you go into
a tense attention so he starts inside
but then it always will manifest itself
externally so you're coming through like
when you when you take your candy you go
like this you see that so the center is
being projected with this fashion you
see but you're in this position
so again this is not self-defense and
you are as UK
harmonizing the image on as much as Naga
is so when you feel the gone
you don't go wrong okay you go in and
that way you are training in the same
art at the same time okay but this this
this part I'm going to be frail and
fragile I'm going to expect the rule not
to push on me right this entitled oh
this is this is a road you don't want to
take it does not work it leads only to
insanity okay so think about it you
can't keep up with the grid because
you're the majority of your mass is
pulling against your grip do you see
that and then your pitcher grips not
good enough to handle it the bouquet
strip should not leave the class to stay
connected got it
so in other words for their center to
stay in the contact point you don't need
your fingers to keep that relationship
if you try to use your fingers then
you're not using your Center and now
you're sent your majority of your weight
your center is pulling against your grip
you won't be able to stay up the person
who is using their Center in this case
pocket it's going to override
[Music]
it's very it's very relaxed but you
can't you can't compromise so it's very
relaxed there's nothing in it so at any
point where if you pushes it doesn't
doesn't do anything doesn't do anything
I stay in then I go through his arm to
his Center okay then here trying to you
know you're not pulling the person so
instead of thinking in a dog's cushion
full think more Dauntless projection and
in his adherence okay so it's projection
and then I am sticking he's sticking to
me so he's he's pushing and it's just
very wrong
they've been here the whole time very
relaxed
and I'm I'm
keeping that zero pressure should be
adhesiveness Dixit idea oh it's just if
I stay at zero pressure there's enough
friction between our skin and our key
and all that has done okay so even if my
holy gym a tiny bit of it and then I go
to a more active that's better okay okay
but in training it's good to to keep
that okay your reparations
[Music]
okay Thomas
to read yourself from the external
poverty see did you want to hold and as
you do whatever let's say you start to
drop down there so with what when I we
use the pattern to get us there but then
I gotta free myself from the pattern
okay so it wherever I'm at I can find
his Center fine so I just relax
Amy Amy to you since wherever you were
happy will allow me okay do you
understand so it's like wherever you
touch me I can find your Center okay
we're just starting here for training
purposes so watch your over eyes on this
okay just it's the feeling you want the
feeling from here goes to there right
then then here you're like okay when
pulled into and pushes right and so
you're waiting for your who get a turn
to enter and then you move out of the
way like a bullfighter hey hey
so again free yourself from the pattern
I am actually
moving into that you see that so it
looks like my maybe I I get it on the
pattern is looks like it but not really
cuz I think it always looks more relaxed
than the other one you see and so the
same thing with this one I I am actually
moving so and I can only move them so
much and that's what I move my body to
I'm not moving my okay
[Music]
so that would be the external
application you forgot your Timmy stuff
you'll must see the face and see the
opening that is just your way of being
now
so when you reach out it's not reaching
out until you try to pull it in if you
didn't pull it in
it would just be touching it and then
from that touch point you would do Ikey
and you could get him to move with you
do you understand okay so just touch it
okay I want to touch it touch it don't
pull it this is this is these two points
here is where you get that action board
I'd send a wait yeah you see you see how
I'm doing that so I'll use the the ID on
the on the it's fine until you pull on
it okay